[Musica]
qual è la vostra prima reazione davanti
all'immagine come questa paura
probabilmente invece leone sta solo
sbadiglianti non c'era aver paura però
la reazione è giusta e il nostro
cervello si è evoluto in modo da
riconoscere velocemente il pericolo per
poterci difendere
quali sono i pericoli che percepiamo
nella nostra vita quotidiana non so se
vi riconoscete in questa indagine però
sembra che abbiamo molta paura di
attacchi terroristici degli incidenti
aerei
ne abbiamo un po meno del riscaldamento
globale e dell'elettrosmog è decisamente
meno del cancro e di incidenti d'auto
però se andiamo a vedere i dati
statistici che stanno dietro al pericolo
reale di questi eventi
vediamo che la realtà è molto diversa
il cervello umano non è adatto a
processare dati statistici a processare
grandi quantità di dati
le macchine ci battono lo sappiamo ci
hanno battuto ago ci hanno battuto a
scacchi
la chiamiamo intelligenza artificiale e
non è neanche una novità perché fece
scalpore negli anni 90 il fatto che un
computer si chiamava deep blue potesse
giocare a scacchi contro l'allora
campione del mondo e vinse vinse anche
nel 97 e perché vinse
secondo il giornale dell'epoca la
macchina era stata migliorata e riusciva
a esaminare addirittura 200 milioni di
posizione al secondo quindi riesce a
fare una grande quantità di calcoli in
poco tempo che un cervello umano non
riuscirebbe mai a fare però se guardiamo
poi l'immagine completa troviamo una
persona sito vicino al diploma
sapete perché serve solo a spostare le
pedine sulla scacchiera
quindi è un compito di coordinazione
senso motoria che per la persona
evidentemente banale ma per la macchina
è molto più difficile di giocare a
scacchi e in effetti nel nostro cervello
il ragionamento logico questo tipo di
capacità si sono evolute recentemente in
termini evoluzionistici mentre è ben più
radicata la coordinazione senso motorio
cioè quello che serve per vivere nel
mondo reale per cacciare per sfuggire ai
predatori per sopravvivere e questa è
una sfida molto più difficile per le
macchine anche più interessante perché
potremmo costruire forse macchine più
utili e in effetti la sfida attuale
dell'intelligenza artificiale della
robotica il gioco del calcio
nel 2050 una squadra di calcio di robot
umanoidi autonomi giocherà contro la
nazionale che in quell'anno si sarà
aggiudicata i campionati mondiali ora in
questo i robot o ancora non ci hanno
battuto
[Musica]
e tuttavia ne abbiamo paura ma abbiamo
paura dei robot abbiamo paura che ci
sostituiscano abbiamo paura che prendano
i posti i nostri posti di lavoro abbiamo
paura di robot che non ci sono ancora e
che invece dovremmo sperare di avere a
fare certi lavori certi lavori che per
l'uomo sono troppo faticosi pericolosi
questi si è perché non ci sono eroi
perché i robot che funzionano così bene
nelle fabbriche ancora non riescono a
svolgere questi lavori e perché invece
di esseri viventi si allora proviamo a
capire quali trucchi ha trovato la
natura per far funzionare sistemi
complessi come un altro essere umano in
qualsiasi altro essere vivente in un
mondo complesso il trucco della natura
non è
cercare di processare tanti dati sempre
più rapidamente il trucco della natura è
ridurre in maniera intelligente la
quantità di dati da processare
nel mio istituto abbiamo studiato un
animale un po particolare che non fa
pensare subito alla robotica
il polpo comune è solo un mollusco ma
riesce a fare cose strabilianti con un
corpo complesso e in un ambiente
complesso ma incredibile capacità di
manipolazione ma anche di locomozione e
questa interessante per la robotica
perché i robot non camminano sott'acqua
normalmente non è molto efficiente
camminare sott'acqua il colpo lo fa e
allora studiando il poco cercato di
capire qual è il principio che si basa
sul fatto che il suo corpo è
completamente morbido il suo braccio si
può allungare accorciare e può rimanere
come rete anche sollevato dal fondale
ridurre l'attrito e abbiamo verificato
questo questo principio su un prototipo
molto semplice da far funzionare però è
poi costruendo un modello matematico che
spiega questo principio che si può
progettare un robot con forme e
dimensioni diverse
come mi trovo che avete visto silver che
per il national geographic ha fatto una
missione sul relitto all'isola d'elba
dimostrando non solo come cammina
sott'acqua ma anche come riesce a stare
completamente fermo con dispendio
energetico molto molto basso nel
progetto blur e solutions la sua
evoluzione silver 2 aggiunge alcuni
principi studiati nel granchio e va a
esplorare i fondali e raccogliendo dei
campioni di sedimento per misurare poi
la presenza eventuale di microplastiche
quindi cosa ci ha insegnato il polpo ci
ha insegnato a camminare sott'acqua ma
c'è anche fatto capire come possiamo
studiare gli esseri viventi per
costruire dei robot utili
ora tutto questo è avvenuto in italia ma
come è messa l'italia nella robotica
qual è la vostra percezione nella
ricerca siamo messi molto bene
la ricerca si misura in numero di
articoli scientifici e questa ci
posiziona in testa sesto posto nel mondo
quindi un'ottima posizione per un paese
relativamente piccolo e terzo in europa
ma abbiamo anche una bellissima
tradizione di aziende di robotica
industriale più recentemente di robotica
di servizio e anche in questo caso nella
classifica mondiale siamo decimi in
europa siamo quarti sono un buon
posizionamento poi pensiamo sempre che
però queste start up piccole ad
altissima tecnologia che poi diventano
molto ricche nascono in america si
sviluppano in america è vero verissimo
però nel settore della robotica
l'europa è competitiva e supera anche un
pochino agli stati uniti e in questo
scenario l'italia una bellissima ottava
posizione
però l'italia ha molto più di questo non
ha soltanto la tecnologia il futuro
della robotica oggi è un'impresa
multidisciplinare dobbiamo ripensare i
modelli economici per poter utilizzare i
robot del mondo del lavoro anziché
ottenerli dobbiamo immaginare e studiare
i modelli sociali del futuro anziché
farceli imporre la tecnologia dobbiamo
disegnare un contesto normativo per
l'introduzione di robot nella società e
naturalmente garantire il rispetto di
principi etici e l'italia il miglior
posto per fare questo non solo perché
abbiamo una tecnologia e abbiamo
l'industria ma perché abbiamo una
tradizione culturale che ha
profondamente radicata nelle scienze
umane e quindi l'italia è il posto
giusto per progettare oggi i robot
sostenibili di domani
grazie
[Applauso]